en fait c'est un choc pendant plus de
trente ans danièle sauvageau s'est
impliquée a tout les niveaux du côté
féminin
si elle a été surprise par la non ce
elle pense qu'il est temps de revoir le
modèle actuel trop centralisée l'aller
dans le modèle actuel c'est-à-dire de
gérer la lega travers toronto mais pas
sur un modèle de franchise où toutes les
décisions sont prises à toronto c'était
difficile pour chacune chacun des clubs
d'aller chercher soi des commanditaires
soit 2 d'élargir l'encadrement soit de
vraiment travailler sur un modèle qui
était peut-être plus adaptable ou
adaptés aux régions
un des problèmes est qu'une équipe comme
les canadiennes de montréal ne pouvait
pas aller chercher ses propres
commanditaires
elles dépendent financièrement de la
ligue à toronto ce qui explique
peut-être le faible budget total de
fonctionnement d'un peu plus de 3
millions de dollars et des joueuses qui
pour les meilleurs étaient payés de dix
mille dollars par saison
la solution pourrait venir de la ligue
nationale de hockey qui pourrait créer
un championnat féminin d'ailleurs bill
daly l'adjoint au commissaire gary
bettman a précisé dans un courriel
envoyé au réseau sportsnet la lnh
étudierait la possibilité d'aidés pour
créer des solutions de rechange danièle
sauvageau pense qu'on pourrait imiter ce
qu'a fait la ligue nationale de
basket-ball la nba en créant une ligue
nationale féminine qui profitent entre
autres de réseaux de diffusion et des
commanditaires si on avait justement un
leadership c'est de regarder les gros
marchés de voir les associations avec
les clubs de la ligue nationale de
porter un peu comme leur club-école aidé
à les réunir non seulement les
meilleures joueuses en amérique du nord
mais les meilleurs joueurs sur la
planète
cette annonce arrive à un bien mauvais
moment à l'heure où les joueuses
canadiennes vont amorcer leur
championnat du monde en finlande
à en croire les bois optimiste qui
s'élèvent les solutions vont sans doute
voir le jour avant le début de la saison
prochaine mercredi radio-canada à
montréal
[Applaudissements]